I spent we gonna give you 30,000 bucks
and then he wanted me to go to you know
[ __ ] Europe and my boyfriend flipped
the [ __ ] out he's the one who turned me
out on dope I'm good long any no Dan I
had another sugar daddy I don't want to
say big rock star
he's definitely on very gay I don't look
like I'm the ugly I'm gonna LG announces
well that's how I was younger so I
always tell girls okay you're gonna take
beauty when you're young now older so I
was told does it use your beauty to your
beanies you could sing the last long you
know to make a long story short dinner
on I met these my field guys my friend
ripped him off we had run away in the
desert million night in Vegas we she
burned them you again these are boss
mobsters
yeah no we're Andy that's how I ended up
in LA she in the mill the night she laid
Kitty we gotta go I'm like what she's
like huh I grabbed them I said what
those are what are you [ __ ] nuts and
we're here taking across the desert in
in midnight the dead desert in you know
Los Angeles not Los Angeles a dirt it's
sister clothing Network it was at
Sherman Oaks playtime I worked the
seventh veil in Hollywood you know crazy
girl Brea
this when I was young I autumn clubs
where we bag it down what bag the babies
worked it uh what's that one that's
these new big new ones experiment Ryan
alright it not those not really don't
reason why I got jobs um I had oh yeah I
can cover my whole why would be naked
but like a mermaid I can come my whole
body up my hair my really long at Dick's
ain't like that now any like perfect so
anyway so I got jobs they cuz there
this one place is really you have to be
really good to get a job here and for
five years in the [ __ ] of the club
you like it you'll never get a job here
you'll never get hired but uh because no
name [ __ ] you have to win like three
contests of it anyway so I walked it I
was really discouraged funny for five
years I went in here I auditioned I got
the [ __ ] job this [ __ ] to get some
man I never lost no idea I came at one
thing under my belt I never every club I
ever played for I I never got turned
down I was really good
you heard I was good at what I did you
know whoever else is when you know
there's a short leash being on that
career but I got a it was really I'm at
myself because I went I had enough money
to buy a house where time I was like 25
but I [ __ ] it off I snorted it is that
sucker on
oh yes [ __ ] delete delete delete
it may also a short [ __ ] because I need
it I need I need a facial okay I'm gonna
do dumb or answer to this all right
yeah I don't take you I'm scared
because I ruined myself I ruined my
second drug abuse driving up here
now Heidi right now my the self-esteem
is in the [ __ ] hole if I sell outside
because one day I when I got a look in
the mirror to recognize myself there's a
time when you get older they're gonna me
I'm like who the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] in
the mirror name maybe she didn't leave
me now like I freaked out like because I
did certain things that make movies that
person who is that person
so my self-esteem shot so so what are
you doing anyway long story short I met
somebody might take care of everybody he
died on me because I was retired and a -
boyfriend - died on me and what [ __ ]
up okay I got drug abuse a I squandered
it was my money I made a lot of money
and it's gone dog except I already have
a million dollars mr. Scott - Elliot's
blowing what are you using
you got you clothes you figure it out
yeah I'm mad at myself because like
anyway this is too deep you got anyone
out usually I don't get disclosed I'm
not open like this but I did I did way
too much of something and just all the
no filters just I'm Q can i outside you
know today night I started meeting on
like you know I analyze I am II would
meet older guys and they would take care
of me you know and as I was doing that
you know you know I learned you know hey
first I was stubborn I'm like [ __ ]
jewelry
yeah so yeah I learned that it's not a
stripper to show me the ropes the hustle
the game all this yeah no I don't know
what this is my I think reason why my
husband died and I this is my karma I
deserve it
hey I I think this is all a bad [ __ ]
that's happening to me now good I didn't
picture my life like this I pictured
dad's gonna get married we'll grow old
with a guy you go all together go on
cruises and go do to go maybe raise some
grandbaby you don't do like though the
white cake your parent don't own it and
you know why God took all that away from
me he died he died to that the reason
would that took away from me because of
all the crap I did when I was in the
club scene or the shitty [ __ ] I
dissolution and so right like my I
deserve I get what's coming to me
I'm a secret ninja dog yes thank you for
talking hey you're really good
Hey